hey what's up welcome back to another
episode of visual effects artist react
we got a very unique episode today we
are joined on the couch by James
Willingham who's from the third floor
you guys specialize in previous stuff
this is where movies are born this is
where the action scenes are ideated upon
raw pixels and polygons into something
that gives you
emotion so I haven't actually seen this
show yet but this one shot right here
may have hyped me up enough to actually
go check this out this is pretty sick a
lot of the stuff we do isn't ten seen
it's it's very early in development I I
promise it's going to look
amazing I imagine it's very rewarding to
see like it's a completely different
thing now but it's still the same idea
and the same concept it's it's an
amazing feeling I would love to to see
an example of what this looks like let's
check it
[Music]
out
s my
only
oh you did prey dude I freaking love
this movie oh yeah
awesome I love how it I love how it just
feels like it's video game animations
but at the same time like the animation
and like the cinematography and the
directions like way nicer than you
expected to be based on like the
graphics cuz you used to like Graphics
like this playing a video game being
from like a janky video game right but
suddenly like whoo there's all this like
Direction and storytelling and the and
the camera work and this you know
cinematography and the blocking this is
right at the end of the project and the
team at this point had shrunk down to a
single person being myself and I had one
week to finish it and then we were done
that's what like you see like these the
deer and stuff just slide chest piecing
along sliding sure yeah um I would have
meetings with Dan trenburg then
brainstorm and and you know go over the
shots and we would find new shots
together it was super fun it was an
amazing collaboration so you're keeping
it in like a rough State because you
need to work on it fast right you need
it's like you're sculpting you just need
to like be able to throw stuff on look
at it take it off and switch it around
exactly yeah did you hand animate that
or is that map at all this was all key
framed that's so I key framed all of
this yeah what would cause this to
depart from the previous why did this
depart from the previous sometimes
they're like this will be too difficult
to get the camera in this position or
maybe this is too much for the stun
actor to perform or it's just time comes
down to it I think again like like I was
saying before sometimes it's just about
helping them think and getting the DNA
of the idea in there just because it's
not a carbon copy um doesn't mean we
didn't help them quite a
bit
this was our this was Pitch Fizz um that
was used to help get the film greenlit
kind of like show The Producers like
this is what it's going to kind of feel
like what it's going to kind of look
like right exactly I love that because
you're showing producers you have to put
a little bit more effort into making
sure it looks
better how do you communicate to them
how do you put them in the mind space to
ignore the things that aren't finished
and pay attention to the things that
matter when I speak to a director or
whoever I all say listen if we can get
it across to you this way it would be so
quick and save so much time and usually
if you convey that information and they
understand that that it's going to save
them time and money they tend to jump on
board with it we call it CG goggles it's
like you got to put on your CG goggles
to really kind of just look past the
rough cut version of what we're seeing
and a lot of people their heads don't
fit goggles right right it's like fine
I'll get I'll do a nice previe for you
yeah I promise it's going to look
amazing you have uh all the Assets in
the scene you have the cinematography
you have the animation which of those
things would you say is the most
important I would say story and in in
this case like is conveying exactly what
needs to happen they need to know where
the cameras need to be you know in terms
of like how they're going to shoot it um
they need to know what lenses they're
going to need they need to know what the
character is going to have to do are
they going to are they going to have to
have a stunt person you know what
specifically is that stunt person going
to have to do it really helps just
convey to the crew everyone else that's
going to work on this and try to execute
this and make it look real later exactly
what they're going to need to do when
you're building out that out do you need
to worry about how it's going to be shot
on set or do you just start with
whatever comes to mind typically you
want to try to avoid cheating as much as
you can because you don't want to design
design something that they get on set
and they're like this is impossible
we're never going to be able to do this
and those are things that we're
definitely conscious of when we're
planning these things okay so you're
actually thinking about how it needs to
be reproduced in real life right
absolutely yeah and sometimes you know
when you're when you're quickly racing
through a sequence and you're just
trying to figure out the story of it
you'll you'll go back to do Tech viz and
get more technical with it so I'm
hearing a new term come from you that we
haven't said on the show ever which is
techviz we've heard previz okay we
haven't heard techviz and posst and
pitch pitch all the visit we're vising
out in a film where there's a ton of CG
stuff that's going to be in there or
that or if they were just planning
something well how are we going to do it
you'll achieve it you'll get the the
sequence approved all the shots are done
now they're like okay well how do we do
it you know and we'll go in there and
we'll we'll we'll techvis everything and
you'll do like a camera sort of a God's
eye view for example Le different angles
showing what the camera's doing the rig
you'll have measurements in there as the
camera's moving around oh now it's 4T
now it's 2 feet from the subjects and
it's incredibly helpful so it really is
a blueprint but for everybody on set the
entire team correct huh you call the
final version of the movie like final
viz final viz we do now final viz V2 V3
final for real final Vore final final
uncore for real this
time
hey Nico hey friend no one will save you
previous
[Laughter]
[Music]
Corridor this is no one will save you
scary alien invasion story that that
crinkling like right this was Lance
Darden who was our previous supervisor
on it and then our
post third floor we did board this
working you know close ly with the
director and getting that all planned
out and approved so you guys actually
boarded this we do have like at third
floor we do have a a story department
and they'll board things uh uh so we'll
create an animatic with that once that
was done Lance went through and did a
chest piece Master scene of the whole
thing kind of like from a God's eye view
chest piecing like sliding the
characters around then they would go in
and flesh out the shots so what is this
now what are we looking at here this
look this looks like it's the post Fizz
done by Mr Brian Carney one of our
supervisors post
yeah post viz got a new viz again so
here we've got the actual film plate so
what we've added here is the CG
character on the roof but the idea here
is just to kind of like get everyone on
the same page about what it's going to
look like you're not necessarily trying
to go out and make final visual effects
happening here right right correct yeah
I like that he Splats on the ground now
he slips like whoops
right so like an idea like that where it
comes down and he's like upside down but
then looks at the camera like that it's
all very other worldly and uncanny how
much of that is coming from the director
like making the beat sheet for this or
whatever this one in particular I'm not
certain on who came up with that idea I
was asking Lance specifically about that
and he was like man I'm trying to
remember who it was Brian was saying
that part of the challenge was figuring
out how like what the size of this thing
how he would move within this vehicle
how they get him in there realistically
so he couldn't reach the girl cuz he's
got these really long arms you know um
you're trying to tell the story you know
within the frame and fill in the blanks
really with whatever is needed those are
a lot of the technical challenges that
come with post Fizz cuz at that point
it's like okay these are the shots we
don't have the infinite freedom of
coming up with a million different shots
like we have to make it work in these
shots and how do we do it you know in
the most realistic way
[Music]
possible oh it's changed again a little
bit he's just trying to lick that
Moon oh there it is there it is crunch
the gutter
scrunch gutter
scrunch interesting wow they really
committed to the fall now it truly slips
and Falls versus Just Landing right man
it's wild seeing how this transformed
from the previous side of things to all
right now we've shot it but we still
don't know what it's going to look like
yet and then everyone finally gets on to
the same page and it comes out like this
right
[Music]
go go H us there's that Tech Vis
you're talking about there you go
there's some tech yeah with the numbers
and
everything what I love about this is
that it's all the scale like those are
real world units there and we also see
the distance between the camera and the
actor here because you don't want to hit
the actor with the camera right so you
have to accommodate that and it helps
with eyelines you know you know where
that dragon eye is so they can know put
a you know tennis ball or whatever there
ctor can look at this was Joanne Smitty
a previous supervisor in London there it
is look at those eyelines solid and now
we know that the camera is about 5T
behind here that's right I know exactly
how tall that dragon head is in the
projects that youve previsit on do you
know going into it what kind of cameras
they're going to be using oh yeah is
that very important I mean there are
time there are times uh when we'll start
and we don't have that information and
then we'll get it sometimes halfway
through usually they get it to us pretty
early and sometimes they'll be shooting
with several different cameras the
project I'm on right now now there's
there's several different packages that
they're using you know when we get to
the post fiz point you know they'll give
us a list of what what was shot you know
with what camera uh the film back and
the lens and Etc and we'll we'll
recreate those cameras you know
digitally so when we're adding in the
post fiz it's all
accurate the dragon's really well
animated for it being prev yeah it's
cool well they go through a process um
where we'll do a pass at the whole scene
they get that all approved moved then
they would send the shots off to this
company pixo cuz basically they're
rigging it up to go onto their buck that
motion control rig the ACT sit on
absolutely they would do a solve where
for example the buck would only rotate
so but a lot of the times this thing
needs to be flying around you know
sometimes your Your Dragon will be
zipping past your camera so they would
have to do a solve where they would then
take that animation of the flying dragon
and put it onto the camera you know
similar to the way they did with the old
Star Wars movies you know flying the
camera around the
ships
so I haven't actually seen this show yet
I should have but this one shot right
here may have hyped me up enough to
actually go check out watch show pretty
sick on this sequence they didn't have
boards on this one so what they did
though is the director and the dop and
the VFX soup planned out a lot of the
sequence with little like uh toy
versions little little mettes of the of
the dragons and they would film it so
they sort of create a little version of
the sequence with that reference you
know their own sort of
real world privis in a sense and they
would use that as reference to build the
sequence so I think one of the biggest
differences I've noticed between the
previs in the final product is pacing a
lot of these scenes in the final thing
are a lot longer than they are in the
previs to let the moment breathe maybe
just we need a little bit more time to
live in this moment perhaps for sure
yeah you you're throwing the clay on
there getting a very quick rough version
of it and then you kind of once you see
it all in its entirety it kind of helps
you see oh I know ways to make this
better I know ways to make this moment
better it's because it's so early and
it's such a collaboration with so many
different people um it's not like you
write something and then execute it and
it's going to be perfectly exactly what
you did it usually ends up having the
DNA of the idea but it's just it's just
another step to help get to that final
piece so you can really see how this
would need all that planning because all
those shots of the person that you're
getting your principal photography is
happening in the computer the actor is
just like an element at this point but
you need to have that element planned
and you need to have it choreographed
with everything else that's happening
the wind the lightning the rain the
atmosphere flying in clouds is not as
easy to film as one might think because
it tends to be just surrounding you like
a fog to get detail and form and
lighting and all that kind of stuff in
some cases they'll have the editor or an
editor right there like on set on that
you know when they're shooting so they
can just drop shots in right away I know
like Peter Jackson did that at at WETA
how much did Peter rely on previs quite
a bit we prevised tons of material one
of the most challenging sequences I've
ever done maybe like the Dragon M
destroying Lake Town when he crashed
down into the
[Music]
town I pitched this idea to the bfx soup
about the dragon crashing down like a
747 but it was this long sort of
convoluted idea where I had him like
coughing up lava blood and crawling
around BL it was this whole I just kind
of went off the rails and and he was
like all right well let's maybe let's
try to let's let's bring that back down
a bit and what do you have him crash
down that's cool but just have him kind
of get his wing up and fly up and then
crash down and die cuz Peter always
wanted him to fall straight down in like
what was really challenging about it
like was it the just the Nuance like the
technical detail of it yeah with like
getting the getting the the animation
right the path on the dragon you know
how he would fly when he fell down
through the town you know breaking up
all those buildings I was just breaking
up all the geometry myself just
animating all the Geo yeah I wasn't
doing any simulations so something
changes you have to go and change all
that yeah exactly that's a lot of work
um oh yeah like I did it as one big shot
now it's been cut up into different
shots which is which is great I'm glad
they did it yeah I can see why that
would have been really tough it was a it
was a wild one how many iterations did
you go through oh I mean I was I worked
on that shot for weeks couple weeks I
think if I recall sometimes what we do
is we help the director think you know
he'll see what we've done and he'll go
oh God that gave me a great idea and
then he'll you know give you his
thoughts then you go back and you rehash
it and you kind of working together
create this this product like and in the
end when you get to sit there in the
theater and you're seeing it you're like
oh my gosh that idea that idea was mine
but it's you know everybody's ideas all
all kind of hash together animation
department at Wet is so good really cool
team down there I'm I'm still dear
friends with a lot of those guys how do
you get into previz is like does it
require like a very overactive
imagination and a lot of like dedication
to action figure photography or like
what is like how does one get into
previs um well one I think you know a
passion for film we're a bit of
generalists um uh for the most part you
know where we're doing our own tracking
we're doing our own animating in Maya
post Vis you're doing compositing you're
doing the rotoscope you know all the
Roto work some previous artists are good
with uh with effects and simulations but
as far as entry we've got people that we
hire right out of school we've got
people that are more experienced in the
industry that come from an animation
background and sometimes those people
will come in and you have to train them
up on camera and cinematography and
things of that nature because that's
that's another big one with preis is you
really have to understand camera work
and cinematography you know so it's a
little bit of everything you know
performance story compositing all all
that stuff the third floor they have a
YouTube channel you guys are just you're
dropping a show right now right we are
it's called artist versus deadline like
it's where we'll take a couple
supervisors and kind of put them up
against each other we'll give them
different sort of themes and and there's
there's you'll get a list of props and
things like that I think they draw out
of a hat yeah and they'll have a week to
execute uh a little short that sounds
like something we would do I'm I'm on
board with this yeah so in the past
we've looked at animations that people
have made just for fun they have this
crazy energy they kind of they feel like
is and you know those are hidden gems
and I would love it if any of you could
recommend some of those other hidden
gems those really crazy animations that
people are just doing on their own that
have that kind of like that previs
energy I'd love to take a look at them
so we can look at them on visual effects
artists react in the future so leave a
comment they right that's the
thing well James the third floor thanks
for joining us I really appreciate it
hey thanks for having me and you guys do
great stuff and it's cool to uh to be a
part of it so yeah I appreciate it
awesome yeah thanks for stooping down to
the first explore with
us anytime anytime gr have you been
waiting on that for like since we
started the episode you have no
idea that was beautiful I came up with
that like five seconds ago